because you remember specifically when  your parents came to the worst shows  ever yes do you remember when they came  to a show where you were like [ __ ]  yeah  well it was always things that they  would appreciate like if i did  a british mystery show my mom would be  in heaven like she would be like that's  the premium  entertainment  there could possibly be  it's like an interesting detective  who has a british accent who's solving a  mystery every week oh my god my mom  would just be like i'd be your favorite  child did you do that a lot that  character huh  i've never done it but i haven't i've  never done it oh i thought maybe it's  something that you know  because i want to see that character no  i